[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil
ramsey personality is my co-host today
author of the number one best-selling
book debt-free degree and host
of the ever-popular youtube and podcast
show called
the table which a new episode dropped
today
so what would y'all talk about i hadn't
listened to today's yet i hadn't had a
chance
um what's what's who's on uh man uh our
good friends dave uh mignon and big
shakes uh
oh wow yeah yeah yeah those two
world-class entrepreneurs
absolutely and they came on and just
really dove deep into
how they started in in the
entrepreneurship world
how they got over some obstacles and has
a barbecue operation both online and
multiple restaurants and mignon has
a cupcake operation tens of millions of
dollars both of them doing revenue
absolutely both world-class
entrepreneurs and they both started from
nothing
nothing i mean young started with five
dollars and a dream
big shake started in new york with
absolutely nothing and now has three
four shops uh multi-millionaires both of
them
and it was just a great show dave yeah
it was a great show well they're great
friends
yes both of ours yes and um just
love them both and i met big shake
through you you met mignon through me
yeah yeah but uh they uh they're both
just they
they're just inspiring listen i mean
people that want to start something and
hustle and grind
and turn over a rock and step on it man
they get it done
they they're getting it done and they're
both kind of cool real cool
i mean now big shakes he he has that old
man swag you know he
he's just real cool yeah he's got yeah
but he he's got more swagger mignon
she's just she's just her she is he kind
of got
he's got the strut down still she really
is yeah i like it it's good man
i can't wait to listen to it are you a
lovely dad it's called the table
yes with anthony o'neil and uh it's just
dave it's is weekly podcast
coming out and uh it's been on youtube
for quite a while has quite a few
youtube uh listeners and viewers rather
and so you can tune in and learn from
two world-class entrepreneurs this week
anthony he gets a little bit of
everybody on there matthew mcconaughey
was on there the other day
and uh you had a table or a uh a panel
for folks for
uh black history month uh on there and
so there's always something happening at
the table there's always a conversation
and be sure you jump in and
join it and check it out and next week
dave we have some of our uh
influencers we bought in you brought in
we as a team we did we brought in some
young influencers
a couple of months ago and so i
interviewed about half of them oh yeah
and brought them in on the show so
that's going to be
a phenomenal phenomenon good i'm excited
lots of good conversations phone number
here if you want to talk about your life
and your money is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five michelle is with us in
harrisburg pennsylvania hi michelle how
are you
hello i have a question for you guys
and i wondered what you would think
my husband and i have signed papers
through a real estate agent to buy
a double a car apartment a house that
has two
apartments in it from his brother and
um in between the time of signing here
and we have not made settlement yet
uh but the
gutter has fallen on an electric line we
were wondering
whose duty that is to take care of it i
want to say that i didn't
understand whose duty to take care of
what to take care of the
gutter that has fallen on the electric
line a gutter
fell on the electric line well typically
the seller would
present a home that is operable to the
buyer
unless you unless you have specific
language in the
uh if it's a fixer-upper of some kind
uh the uh uh
you know you might have as is where is
in the contract in case
in that case you just bought whatever it
is and you you got the gutter
okay but most of the time when you're
buying a b does it say as
is where is in the contract i'm not
exactly sure
okay it is a fixer-upper although we
haven't made settlements
so that doesn't matter yeah settlement
would be
based on you closing on the deal that
you made
if the deal you made on a fixer-upper is
we're going to fix all the repairs well
a gutter hanging off ain't that big a
deal
to start with but um uh
i kind of have the feeling that you're
getting cold feet
uh i haven't happened
where's your cold feet coming from
michelle
what was that where's the cold feet
coming from the other half of it that
you say
it's half and half uh there's some
family that
thinks that we need to pay more and uh
even though it's not worth
that much who's the family are they the
seller
uh the father-in-law well it's none of
his business unless it's his property is
it his property
no no okay okay well then it's that's
called nunya
yeah none your business and it's also
very important michelle for you to
you need to know what's in your contract
i'm a little yeah uh disappointed that
you don't know exactly what's inside the
contract so the very first thing is you
need to go back and read through
or have an attorney read through
everything so you know exactly what
you're signing for
uh where'd you get this contract this
form
uh the real estate agent we are with oh
there's an agent involved
yes did you ask your agent about the
gutter
no okay that would be a good idea now is
it is it your agent or is it the
seller's agent
michelle both oh it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter they can tell you what
you've agreed to
right you probably are using a standard
form
realtor contract that's a
what's called a boilerplate meaning it's
a standard form
uh and it may even have in it uh
as is where is if you're buying a
fixer-upper they may have added that as
far as repairs go so that they didn't
so that the seller didn't get obligated
uh
to do this if i were selling that
property i would have had that specific
language in there
so that whatever condition the property
is in as of the closing date it's on you
if i'm supposed to present you with a
retail deal meaning everything's [ __ ]
and span and perfect
then it would say that and you would
have gotten a home inspector ahead of
time
if you did this properly and you would
have known exactly what you were getting
into
but i think there's family drama here
and a gutter
is exposing that because let me tell you
what it takes to fix a gutter
200 bucks so it's a non-issue
okay you don't not do a real estate deal
or do a real estate deal over a gutter
that's just not you know there's there's
a lot of other crap going on here
and um it may be that you don't need to
do the deal because of the family drama
yeah and just look at brother and go you
know what everybody's pissed off so
let's just not do this you sell it to
somebody else
and y'all go get something else and but
the gutter doesn't need to be the reason
no and so yeah once you get to
settlement you own the house it's over
then
so so folks here's the deal
everybody says don't do business with
family don't hire family
you know what that's wrong you can do
business with family and you can hire
family i got a family that works here
what's the secret the secret is you have
to be as clear or more clear
in all of the dealings and expectations
and paperwork
than you would with someone that you
never met before okay
because it takes extra layers of
communication to cut through family bs
gotcha you have to be uber super crazy
blunt two before
in the face clear yeah with family where
with normal humans you could just look
at them and say something and they could
hear it
but with family they get all caught up
in assumptions they do
right and so don't assume nothing write
it down like it's a freaking
business transaction because it is
and then you know exactly what you're
getting into and you would never care
about the father-in-law of the seller
were you buying someone else's property
there you go that's how business works
this is the dave ramsey show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five 825-5225 i'm dave ramsey your host
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month
you save a lot always use the magic word
ramsey as your promo code
today's question comes from zach in iowa
my wife and i had a baby in august and
now that we
are debt free we want to start investing
in her future
since we don't know her future plans and
given the talk around the financial
changes
in academia would it be better to invest
in a standard mutual fund instead of a
529
well first zach i want to say congrats
to your newborn uh that's an amazing
amazing thing
uh but for me i'm gonna say stick to a
529 because i would say more than likely
your child is going to want to go to
college and you all are going to push
for further education
and so i would stick to a 529 and just
make some adjustments
there uh once she graduates from high
school if she decides not to go to
college
completely agree the landscape may shift
yeah
it will shift it will it's shifting
already yeah and it's going to shift in
the next
uh number of years but starting a 529
you know and when you get up to ten
thousand dollars you might pause a
second and look around say now do i want
to keep going
right if you get up to fifty thousand
dollars you may wanna pause and look
around
yeah uh long before you get to a hundred
thousand right but you don't have to
you're not making a hundred thousand
dollar decision today
right you can just start one and then as
it gets bigger you keep looking around
and going well this is different now and
this is different and um
what has happened is the argument
and you talk about this in a debt-free
degree yeah
in the best-selling book of yours the
argument
against the cost the extreme
exorbitant cost of a four-year degree
is even stronger and was accelerated by
covid because you can't even freaking go
on campus right
right and so it's basically you're
getting an online degree and everybody's
going well my sure is crowding paying
there for an online degree
right and i was questioning whether i
was going to do it with the college
experience
right but now when there's no college
experience and now it's all online i'm
sure
i could just go on google and get that
you know and so people are uh
that is forcing covet accelerated a
cultural shift
in us observing what's happening with
our education so higher ed's
um they're they're in a mess yes they
are then if the
biden administration goes through on
some of its promises and forgives
student loans
and yet has the hypocrisy
to not stop the student loans yes
see if you're going to forgive them
because they're evil you shouldn't keep
making them
absolutely agree dave because they're
evil yep
you cannot in good car i mean it's
intellectually dishonest
to forgive student loans and continue to
make them right
that's straight up pandering straight up
politicians handing out money
yeah that's all that is that's not a
philosophical
admission that the student loan crisis
is a screw job on the american public
yeah
and if you're going to admit that then
you need to stop making them which
they're not going to do by the way
they're not going to do that dave and i
know we're
totally against debt but at least maybe
put a cap on it you know don't make it
unlimited for these these
people it's just out of control so but
that's what's driven the call up this is
unlimited supply of stupid money yes
there's always somebody who will take
the money yep
and so you know government money which
by the way you don't even have to pay
back if it's forgiven
so i mean this whole thing is getting
super absurd so the guy's quest zach's
question is really good
it's really because that pressure was
all there and then add covered to it
yeah
and you go we're not even on campus yeah
i'm sure not paying 50 grand a year for
this
right and people are starting to wake up
and go hey i want a return on investment
i want to pay
get something you know get something i'm
real proud of for what i paid for so
online learning
or reasonable state schools or community
colleges or
some of the stuff we've been suggesting
to avoid student loan debt for years
yeah are suddenly much more popular but
that's going to change what the
offerings are at higher ed
yeah it really will over time so the
answer your question is zach if
if you said i'm going to put in 200 000
in my kids college fund this morning
i would say yeah i agree with you don't
do that because the landscape's changing
i might not do that all at once
but if you're gonna start gradually
you're not gonna screw up having 10
grand under 529 so let's get started
but then continue to monitor the shift
in
the education culture and what's
expected so now dave let me ask you this
question
uh you have several mutual funds i have
not several i have a couple mutual funds
outside of my roth ira
now let's say if he maxes out his 529
he's already investing in all this other
type of stuff
can would you suggest he opens up
another mutual fund if he just wants to
save more to give more to his kids and
he can just have that in his name though
okay and then that could be used for
anything yes yeah i mean you can just go
i'm gonna buy a piece of real estate
with it
i'm not giving it to the kid i got you
so you can just build wealth and that
always gives you options for doing
anything you want to do
got you a pile of money in your name i
would not necessarily pile a bunch of
money in the kid's name
okay you can if you want to
save some taxes but you lose a lot of
control uh
yep because see that mutual fund if you
put in the kid's name it's called a
uniform um well i can't call it out yeah
my brain went blank but anyway
uniform transfer to miners act the booth
helped me out thanks guys
my brain's locked up but uniform
transfer to miners act and all that
means is
if you open a bank account with your
bank for your child to have
put their milk money in or their
birthday money in because little junior
has a little savings account at the bank
right that's under the uniform transfer
to minors act okay
because it's you can't technically open
an account
unless you're 21 anywhere you can't
because you can't do
you can't do business you can't you're
not an adult so the parent opens the
account
in the child's name typically and the
parent is named the custodian
right and so but then that mutual fund
if we do that
is taxed at that kid's rate so as it
makes money it has lower
taxes than if it was in money got you i
got you because i'm gonna get my butt
taxed off right i know that
right and so it saves you some but again
it's
it's their money right when they turn 21
if they're doing
cocaine they can go get the money yeah
and so you you lose a lot of control
over it
until they're 21. gotcha uh and and so i
you know for what little tax savings
there is i would just open it in your
name and just book on but this higher ed
discussion and we've had it with dr john
delony who's got a phd in higher ed and
he comes out of the
the university world as served in
leadership in multiple different
universities
but we're all observing that this is a
uh
when when the dust settles on this after
covet on
what colleges charge and how many people
attend them physically
it's going to have change it's going to
have accelerated the change yes
that the student loan crisis started yes
and i don't know to what extent but
we're gonna see something shift
absolutely to where you know my my
university university of tennessee at
knoxville with
30 000 students or got a guy sitting out
here with a michigan hat on the
university of michigan or the university
of
uh whatever kentucky or auburn or
alabama
or california or whatever it's gonna
look different yeah and those are state
schools
yeah now if you if you fast forward you
go over into a super expensive private
school
they're going to feel it even more
because people are going to go look
the student loan thing is so bad that
the democrats forgave it so i'm not
signing up
right right because not many people are
so dishonest just to sign up knowing
they're going to get it forgiven
right like i'm going to go get all i can
get so the government pays for it
i'm going to get on welfare because i
don't really want to work you know most
people aren't that
lacking in honor they're not uh so that
it's going to affect it
the the if they do this forgiveness even
if they don't stop making them
it's still going to affect the
perception in the culture it has changed
it's changed permanently
and um you guys check out anthony's book
debt free degree and check out the
borrowed future podcast on the ramsey
network
because it lays out in detail how
crooked and how
i mean filthy yes the student loan
industry
is especially and the government intent
behind it yes
i mean it is a colossal
mess it is an epic failure
man and uh you need to check it out and
so
and if you want to go to school and you
should go to school by the way education
is important i'm not
we're not a group that says you don't
need to go to college it's not worth
anything oh it's worth it it's better to
be smart than dumb it really is
so you should go but you need to be
smart about your education it's
obviously moronic to not be
so i you know in debt free degree i'll
help you learn how to do that
it's uh like i said it's a number one
bestseller
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today you are listening to
the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i am dave ramsey thank you for joining
us america patrick is with us in grand
junction colorado
hey patrick how are you hey dave hey
anthony
uh thank you so very much for taking my
call our pleasure how can we help
well my wife and i read the total money
makeover
uh just two weeks ago wow and
yeah i am 41 years old
and we paid off our debt on friday
uh just three days ago wow
well now dave i gotta tell you someone
gave me one of your books
when i was like 22 years old i'm not
even kidding you
and from that time till this time i've
been on the dave ramsey envelope system
i have been real serious about not being
debt
i bought my wife's wedding ring for cash
i paid for the wedding in cash
my wife and i have really been blessed
because of the book we read of yours i
mean forever ago
okay and so the total money makeover the
other day was just a tune-up then
yeah it was because i i haven't been
listening to the podcast i haven't read
any
more of your books and my wife and i
just looked at where we were and we're
like you know what we need to get on
track
so we only had twelve thousand dollars
in debt we had one
automobile we paid it off um i bought
the total money makeover uh it was the
last purchase i made with my credit card
the book came in the mail and there you
are on the cover cutting up credit cards
so i felt like a dumb dumb for that
it's a blast from me yeah
but here's where here's where we're at
we're on baby step three
and um but we have been investing
a lot of money because we haven't been
on the plan up until a couple weeks ago
so got it
my question is do i pull
some of that out for my six months of
uh fully funded emergency fund or how
much do you have
non-retirement investing
we have 435 000
yes take enough out today and call it
your emergency fund
and put it in a money market right now
let me explain that to you because it
doesn't make sense yeah because you're
going to hear me cry in a minute i don't
know but it's not that much money it's
not that much money
what's your emergency for what is your
three to six months of emergencies how
much
should this fund be so we were thinking
six months should be 36 000 okay so move
30 grand that's enough
yeah you'll be fine because you got 400
other than that laying over there
right okay so it's not that much money
now here's the point okay that 30 000
has a new mission now
its old mission was to grow
as an investment your emergency fund is
not
an investment
if you can swallow that it'll make this
easier yeah
it's not an investment it's insurance
now if you think about insurance versus
investments insurance
costs you money to protect the things
that make you money
your house going up right you don't want
to burn
so we buy an insurance policy to protect
it
so insurance is defense investments is
offense
so we're moving 30 000 over into defense
to protect so we don't have to cash out
some of that 400
at exactly the wrong time because let me
tell you what will happen if you think
i'm going to use the 400 if something
happens right
uh-huh that's what most people think
yeah what happens is
you'll go i still can't cash out the
400.
even though i need 7 000 to do dot dot
emergency
i just can't do it and you'll pop it
onto a credit card
yep yeah and so the emergency fund is
the completed
proper step in a good finance in a good
financial plan
but anthony it's very important that we
change it emotionally from offense to
defense absolutely dave defense is very
very important i love how you called it
out that so you know what
he's going to see that 400 000 over
there he's i don't want to touch that
i'm going to take out a loan
i'm going to put on the credit card and
and then next thing you know he's right
back into what took him about 20 years
to pay off everything
yeah and so defense sets you up for
effective offense
okay and so i love how bad broke that
down but thirty thousand dollars out of
four hundred thousand dollars it's
really not it's not a lot of money
yeah you just ask tampa bay yes
wow defense sets you up for an effective
offense yeah that was a good one dave no
question
i was going for the young man but man
you just hit us hard without i mean it's
just
i i i'm not a fan of either team it's
i'm not i'm not a hater on either team
it's just
just an observation of the game yeah
true you you know it just it sets you up
yeah to win and defense wins games and
defenses
and that's that's not only true in
football it's true in finance and so
because here's what can happen you can
be smart smart smart smart smart smart
smart
yeah and then have a moment and this is
not the case with patrick okay
yeah but just as another example like
i've seen people who build up and they
got 400 grand laying there
right and they've been smart all those
years because patrick's been very smart
right and then suddenly something comes
along that's shiny
this looks like a cool investment that
their friend wants to get them into
and you could put 200 000 over here and
all this
in one stroke of the pen you get stupid
yeah
yeah and i've seen people just suddenly
boom
they just lose it yeah and so that's the
that's the you know you've been really
good at offense but you didn't have a
good defense
to keep you from stepping into stupid
tacks yeah and i've done it i've never
done it on the stage
by the time i went broke i did it yeah
but i mean since then i've even
done stupid things that cost me money
but i have been smart enough after i
went broke to do them small enough
to where they weren't game ending and
there's one other thing too i would
suggest dave and tell me from wrong care
that other 360 000 that he's going to
have there sitting there
give that a give that a purpose why is
it sitting there it needs to go ahead
and do baby steps four five and six yes
so if you've got a home yeah mortgage
pay off your i'm going to start moving
towards that with that other with that
other balance that's going to even be
harder yeah and another discussion but
we'll get through baby step three first
right zachary is with us zachary's in
lexington kentucky hi zachary how are
you
i'm doing well dave can you guys hear me
we can how can we help
good deal one to get you guys opinion on
whether my wife and i
are financially healthy enough to try
and start a business
okay we are 23 and 25
our only debt is we just built
a house for 350 000. uh we currently owe
270 on it okay no student debt
no car debt and we got about 25
000 in liquid cash um built up
you guys are on fire yeah what's your
household income
we're trying to be um our household
income last year was
170. what kind of business are you
wanting to start and what's it going to
cost
one to start a business that is a
solution for
treating hot tubs household hot tubs and
pools
i developed the product based on my own
personal
sufferings and that and we've got it
we've got to develop prototype and the
next step
would be is this a chemical product or a
robotic cleaner
uh chemical product chemical product
okay so you can do it all by yourself
for
to start off right you know me
me and i one of my friends is a he's a
stay-at-home dad
currently he's also debt-free outside of
a mortgage
okay so it's kind of something that we'd
be taking on together
my biggest drawback is
i've got a very good job and yeah i've
got about
a guaranteed i work in sales i do
logistics for a living
yeah so what what do you want to spend
to start the business
uh very minimal only a thousand dollars
well why wouldn't you
yeah and you don't need him and you
don't need to leave your job
you don't need him you don't need to
leave the job just start it
yeah yeah and start selling it and after
you sell a hundred thousand dollars
worth then you can quit your job
and he can work for you there you go but
you don't need a partner the only ship
on sale is a partnership
i got you i mean it's a it's a best
friend kind of deal though it won't be
bringing other people up with you yeah
well that's okay he can work for you and
you can pay him out of the profits
that'll bring him up
that definitely yeah and zach hear me
clearly man
uh you're a young man and i get it we
want to be entrepreneurs
do not leave your job keep working it
until
this can take care of your actual salary
you have coming in
or closed yes but don't don't quit bro
don't
start it out of your garage i talked to
a young man that they started the thing
in his garage seven years ago did 25
million this year
good gracious yeah not bad start it out
of your garage and when it gets up close
to your
current salary then you can quit and
walk away and you need to
um and you need to have your friend work
for you
he doesn't need to be your partner he
said
no you don't need a partner you have the
stuff
you've got the money you got everything
here
[Music]
[Music]
if you feel like you're going to always
be stuck paying off your debt
well you don't have to be you think
you're never going to have any extra
money to save
i think you're always going to be like a
rat in a wheel
well you don't have to be it doesn't
have to be this way it's time for a new
way of thinking it's time to reset
time to take control of your money
instead of it controlling you you can
millions of people have and we show
people how every day and it won't take
as long as you think it will with ramsey
plus we'll kick you off with 90 days of
guided help so you can put more of
your money back in your bank account
you'll learn practical ways to get small
consistent wins
that add up to big results and better
habits and that means you'll get where
you want to be
faster debt-free and spending your money
without worry this year you can
make more progress on your debt and your
saving than you ever have get ramsey
plus
and start living the life you want
faster ramsey plus you can
do a free trial by texting free no no
i'm sorry you text
trial 233 789
you can get a free trial to ramsey plus
that includes financial peace university
includes every dollar plus it includes
the the
you know the premium version everything
text the word
trial two three three seven
eight nine brian is with us in
greenville south carolina hey brian how
can we help hi dave thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up so my question today
actually is
advice on what to do with our tax return
um we've got
about 6 000 planning on coming in from
that and
we're on baby step two so we're choosing
debt to pay off
but at the same time we just bought a
house at the beginning of this year
and it it's an older house 1957
and the inspector said that the ac unit
actually is on its blast life
and that it would probably be going out
soon and we've made it thus far
in the winter but
it from the outside it looks it looks
pretty bad and so
i'm worried that it'll go out if we
spend this
tax return we'll end up having to come
up with money to replace that
hmm so uh let's see you're in greenville
south carolina
and it is february yeah
it's about you don't need an ac yeah
not too bad well it's it's i know
i'm poking fun at you
right so if it goes out in july you go
to walmart and buy a 10
box fan okay
how much debt have you got left
um well not including the house it's
about 30
000. okay what's your household income
sir
uh only about 26 to 30. for you and your
wife combined income
my wife is a stay-at-home mom that's
kind of getting paid under the table to
babysit
okay and what it what are you and so
you're working 40 hours
yeah how old are you 26.
what do you do a forklift driver for a
local warehouse
okay okay all right so what are you
going to be doing when you're 30 that
makes twice what you make now
that's a good question i've i had
surgery a couple years ago
and it is really limiting my options as
to what i can do so i'm still actually
in the process of trying to figure out
what i can do um so it affected you
physically but not mentally
yeah okay so you're gonna do something
that's called white collar
okay yeah right using your brain
yeah any education brian
uh three years of i.t but no graduate
okay all right so why are you not
working in i.t
um because in college i took the same
math class
about three times and wasn't able to
pass it with a high enough degree to
continue in the
core class in the degree classes yeah
but what did you learn did you learn
programming
a little bit of programming and uh
networking
okay so even if you couldn't pass the uh
the math class can you work on a
computer yeah
yes sir i pays more than driving a
forklift
most likely yeah like definitely brian
let me answer this question man
i don't i'm listening to you and i don't
i don't
hear motivation i don't hear aspiration
i don't hear like yo
i really want to do more like what why
why are you living today like where
where do you see yourself what do you
want in the next 10 15 years
well to be honest all the things i
wanted to do i can't i wanted to join
the military i wanted to be in the
police force or something like that
that's more physical
and so i didn't really have a back-up
plan when i heard that i need to be off
my feet
and i t i was never excited about
because that's
um one of my biggest weaknesses is being
a gamer and so
i didn't feel like it would be a good
idea to
be in front of a computer all day you
know with the
chances of getting into different gaming
stuff or whatever
plus i like to be more hands-on so i
didn't want to really be in an office if
i could help it
got you so you're going to be in an
office yeah because you're not going to
be in the military and you're going to
get off this forklift yeah
and you're going to be doing you're
going to be a software engineer dude
yeah
i mean if you love gaming won't we take
all those skills and that love and let's
use it for something
the reason we're going into this is it
solves your air conditioner problem
yes because you don't have an air
conditioner problem you have an income
problem yep right that's why we went
there
okay so we're gonna get the cattle prod
and
zap you off that forklift ready
you feel it so i want you i want you
by uh this time a seat
by the first of march i want you to have
talked to
three people in the technical world
about you doing some side help for them
while you keep your day job yes
i want you to stick your toe in the
water and reset your dream
you're too young to have your only dream
destroyed and you do nothing the rest of
your life
you have too much potential there's too
much for you to do in this world
yeah god was not surprised that you got
hurt and he has a plan for you
right mm-hmm and
and i don't think there's nothing
there's no shame in driving a forklift
but i don't think you're there because
it's your passion to drive a forklift i
think you're there because you're hiding
yeah yeah and it was the easiest answer
yeah like it was operating equipment it
was default
it was whatever program came up when you
turned it on yeah
yeah and here's the thing brian dave
told you something that's key and i do
not want you to miss it and before you
hang up i want you to stand online
because kelly
is going to give you one of our friends
ken coleman's uh book the proximity
principle
he told you to talk to three people in
the tech world and work for them on the
side
what's key is there is that not only
will you get income on the side but
you're going to build relationships
what if you could make 200 000 a year
working for a company that creates games
that's it and that starts with the
relationships as a gamer
well i think that would be better than
any plan you had
absolutely probably even the other plan
that was your glory plan
yeah i mean cause you love gaming
and your brain works that way i know
that because you gravitated towards tech
yeah none of this was an accident yeah
so hey man i just i i want good things
for you okay so what i'm gonna tell you
is i'm gonna tell you to take that six
thousand dollars
and pay it on your debt and i want you
to get an extra job in the tech world
and pay off your debt even faster and
while you're working that extra job if
your air conditioner goes out this
summer
you can stop your debt snowball for a
little bit work 100 hours a week
and at the extra tech job and then buy
you an air conditioner
yeah but right now i want you working to
that snowball but dude
this is not about your debt snowball i
think we got a hold of it it's about
your career track
and hold on kelly's going to pick up
we're going to give you a copy of ken
coleman's book go to kencoleman.com
his website download all of his stuff
it's all free
and we gave you the only thing he
charges for which is the book
and he will walk you through how to get
this going man
yeah and uh but it's exactly what you
need to do
you need to start poking around the
career of the tech world
and get off that forklift uh because
that's not going to take you where you
want to go
it's not because it wasn't your goal i
mean i got a friend that owns a forklift
company if you want to own a forklift
company you can do it
yeah if you if that's what you want to
do but i don't think that was your plan
nah
you can hear it all in his voice dave
and that's one thing
well time is up but you called him out i
did you called him out i didn't call
about that you just
for his own good though that was a bus i
love bus yes sir all right
you loved it yeah
oh that puts this hour of the ramsey
show
in the box
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality is my co-host
today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five as we talk about your
life then we talk about your money
and we talk about your life and we talk
about your money
and it's all here starting off this hour
is gonna be
cedar falls iowa elise is with us hi
elise how are you
good how are you all better than we
deserve what's up
um so i just want to say um thank you
for everything that you
and ao do especially i am loving that
black panel uh conversations on his
youtube channel
um my question today is not so much
financial but just personal um so
i'm just wanting to know like the
boundaries and guidelines of
when it's appropriate to talk to a
friend about a big life decision
um and the fine line of wanting to help
them
um but not may not be close enough um to
the person to
have the right to say anything on the
subject so
my uh friend is in a relationship
with this a very um very nice man
um but she is a believer and he is not
and she is adamant that she doesn't want
to marry
any guy who is a non-believer
and during this process their
relationship they he's been very close
to becoming a believer
but they have had discussions of
potentially becoming
engaged maybe in like the next month or
two
and my big concern is that
she's that she's just going to get lost
and it's going to be really difficult
for their marriage
and he knows that she won't marry him
unless he's a believer
and so i'm just worried that the
pressure of engagement is going to
make him decide a decision that
isn't actually what he decides and he's
actually going to want to
become a believer not because of the
faith but or
his relationship with christ but more so
to be with the girl and i just
don't know if i am the right person to
have that conversation i'm close with
her
um and i've kind of been announcing the
shoes were reversed
yeah and she came to you could you hear
her
i think so um is she close enough to you
yeah to tell you some kind of a hard
have a hard conversation with you and
you hear it
yeah well then you're close enough to
her yeah
and here's the thing um say it
say it with love say it one time and
move on
yeah amen you know this is not your this
is not your crusade right
this is a concern yeah don't lose any
sleep over it
uh pray about it talk to her if she she
receives
it great if she doesn't you did your
part as a friend
but do not allow this and her decision
for her life
to impact you and how you're moving
forward
and also on the flip side and i could be
wrong here so correct me firmer on dave
this could potentially hurt the
relationship depending on how she
receives it
and you have to be okay with that as
well
yeah yeah that's the risk yeah real
friends will risk pissing somebody off
absolutely otherwise you're not a real
friend
yeah right now we're not setting out to
make them mad we're not setting out to
hurt them yeah but you're will
you know you know that that's a risk so
if i were
in your shoes what i would do is i
wouldn't make statements i would ask
questions
that's so good dave write down five
questions
and it might say okay you told me
long before you met so and so that you
did not want
to marry someone who did not share your
faith in christ is that still true
that's question okay
um are you going to in
now that he's in the picture it appears
you guys are getting
really serious and the reason i'm
talking to you about this
is is i'm worried for you
and i want you to have a good life
because i love you you're my friend
and so i if he does not share
your faith are you going to go forward
and marry him anyway
that's the second question you might ask
um third question is how do you think
that's going to work out
yeah yeah i mean
these are questions and a part of that
and part of that third question is
they even go deeper that question is if
y'all do get married
how is that going to work out for your
family
how are you going to teach your kids you
know if y'all have two doctrines
that you don't believe on you know
um and then ask her a soft one ask her
when it doesn't really
come off so hard like hey so how is the
relationship going
that may be something to start off with
and the the only other one i would throw
in
is are you concerned this is passive
aggressive but it's still a question
are you concerned he might pretend
to convert to a person of faith in order
to put a ring on your finger
yeah and if she says yes to that i might
then say how can you guard against that
but you know what dave the answer to
that question is time
yes slow down and those young men
we are known for saying yes to something
or doing something that we already know
we really don't want to do
just to get the hand in marriage you
know and so
that's a real good question dave yeah
and just slow down
yeah anything listen if she's just all
bubbly and over the top and is not
listening
and shuts you down on a series of five
six questions that sound like that
then you've done your job right because
you really cannot
you know it is not illegal to be stupid
if it was i'd have been in jail a long
time ago
[Laughter]
yeah i mean you're going to watch part
of being grown up is you're going to
watch people that you love
in your family and outside your family
people that you love
do things that are harmful to themselves
and you really can't do squat about it
it's just hard yeah it's hard watching
your friends drive their car right
towards the wall
it is it's hard watching your uh friends
hit the wall it is
or family members you know and you go
there's a wall
i know but it's fun
yeah i think the part for me davis it's
hard up front but after i've set my
pieces
not hard you got to walk then though you
got to be a you cannot be
it's not a crusade it's five questions
yep
keep and it's short and it's very clear
don't sugarcoat it
yeah and don't turn it into a preaching
session that's good
you're not there to preach yeah you're
there to ask questions
and that she should be asking herself
yeah and you're just clarifying and
you're saying
okay it sounds to me like you're going
to go forward with this and i'll just
tell you i'm going to pray for you
because i'm really concerned
yeah and then you just walk away from
the subject and you can stay in her life
but she's not the translation those my
grandmothers should say those convinced
against their will are of the same
opinions still
yeah yeah and i would definitely on this
show people call in and
after the third time that they want to
argue with the same advice that i've
given for 30 years
you hang up on them i just i'll put them
on hold and move on
because i talk to somebody that actually
wants the advice because
otherwise i'm just arguing with a wall
yeah i just you you know what wasn't my
dad
you'd argue with the fence post y'all
ever heard that one argue with the fence
post
but you know what dave country thing i
want to encourage her to listen to john
delony so he
he did a video on how to have the hard
conversation with the loved one
lots of questions yes this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions with
a question is scott from los angeles hey
scott how are you i'm good thanks guys
good how can we help um i just uh well
my wife and i uh been listening for a
long time just paid everything off
except for the
the house way to go thank you and uh
we've decided we'd like to
leave california we're kind of tired of
it hey man yep
so we've we're heading out here you're
the only one
i wish that was true maybe two years ago
would have been better but we're here
uh on our way and uh we're kind of
surprised in a way because a couple
years ago home values were a little bit
lower and
we've realized that things are more
expensive and now it seems like it's
going to be more of a lateral move
as far as uh the mortgage is concerned
um we will save money
but not as much as i thought and so
that's of concern i
i thought it would be a you know we'd
have more money left over if that makes
sense uh sure what part of california
you're in uh we're down in los angeles
okay and what part of l.a marina del rey
okay
and you're comparing that to williamson
county here exactly
okay in tennessee outside of nashville
yep okay
um well home prices have gone up here
but they've not gone up
uh they've not doubled or anything like
that
um and they're still considerably lower
than
marina del rey uh per square foot and so
forth now you are it's
four square feet yeah oh yeah you can
get a bigger house for sure yeah but
yeah it's easier
so the homes that you're liking over
here are gonna use up the money from
over there
okay and um
well it's uh it's not a move down in
that regard then because you're going to
move up in lifestyle better schools we
don't have to worry about the homeless
out with our children but i mean and
you're talking about more square feet
huge 14 yeah 1400 versus 4700 yeah it's
shocking yeah okay so that's
uh yeah um how much of a how much of a
home are you looking to buy
the homes here that i'm looking at are
anywhere between a million and i'd say
one to one point five yeah let's say i
thought it'd be
i thought it'd be 770. but that was a
couple years that's the average around
here
yeah um well the difference is is that
um
the prices didn't go up so much as the
square footages went up in the area
right
the the size of the mcmansion in
williamson county's larger because
williamson county is the 11th wealthiest
county in the nation right now
uh it has attracted so much wealth into
this area it started with health care
and country music people and then it's
gone from there
and i moved in and brought the
neighborhood down but um
but the uh uh uh but yeah that's that's
so yeah it's just a you know you're
gonna get 4700 instead of 1400 you're
gonna get a different
uh environment that you're gonna live in
we'll just call it that to be nice
and uh so
i penciled the numbers out and it's
going to save me a couple grand a year
and that's not including state income
tax including taxes not including
everything i'll just
you know just move over the the mortgage
is about the same yeah i'd love to pay
the mortgage off someday but it's going
to take some time
yeah well you i mean as long as you're
doing it on a 15-year fixed or less
and uh you you know you're still young
you've got plenty of time to knock that
thing out you've still got a game plan
to knock it out
you know put it on a 15 plan knock it
out in 7 to 10 which is what i would
tell
anybody anywhere then that doesn't
really change
in this situation but more than anything
you're just this
trip over you're just getting you got a
little sticker shock this time
yeah i expected just to kind of take a
look at the area understand where
everything was
and then there happened to be a house
that kind of fell out
and that it's hard to find these you
probably can do what you're talking
about doing it won't be down
all the way to from a million and a half
down to 700 but
you probably could take a step back like
where you were in the other trip but
you're going to go out one more county
right uh into a much more rural setting
and you're going to get a different vibe
in that county you're going to be in
rural tennessee rather than in suburbia
tennessee
uh if you do that but uh you know that's
you know again your step there's lots of
wonderful counties around here this
isn't the only one but
this is just the most expensive one
where you're standing
yeah but um yeah i mean i i don't i
don't i wouldn't say you're making a bad
financial move
okay you know you're not you're not
being irresponsible or something by
doing this
but it sounds like you're just
experiencing a little bit more of the
just sticker shock and seeing the houses
are just so massive
it does kind of shock you for a moment
i'm in a 30-year fixed loan over there
so switching over to a 15 if i tried it
that would probably that would change
things yeah i'd probably be stuck with a
another 30 i would think and listen
you probably could buy less than 4 700
if you look around too
yeah that's that's possible i mean
there's there's other things in the
market in the 3000 range and that kind
of thing
footage wise still double your square
footage sure but um
and you know again it may just it may
just be one of the things i do when i'm
looking at property in an area that i
don't know
um is i just enjoy the whole process
of gathering every stinking piece of
information
in other words i want to know every
neighborhood yeah i want to know this
one over here and
anthony's had you know he had a lot tied
up out in uh an area that's
just out south of here he's going to
build a house and he decided not to and
you know and then he ended up in
downtown nashville and uh in a
re-gentrified area and so forth and so
uh
i just enjoy the gathering of
information and i think you might
need to do a little bit more of that too
that might give you some more options it
may lead you right back to where you
were
but you might be more comfortable with
the option that you're looking at today
after you've used the others to swing
you back over to it
if that makes sense does that make any
sense yeah yeah it's it's
it's um it's hard to go back though i
don't think i can go back
and i just finished paying off me and my
wife 400k so we're
way to go yeah we're uh well welcome to
tennessee brother thank you ma'am good
to have you
thanks guys open phones this hour this
is the ramsey show anthony o'neil
is my co-host today ramsey personality
answering your questions julie is with
us in washington d.c
hey julie how are you i'm good how are
you dave
good how can we help i'm calling today
with a question
about um using an inheritance that i
received to
either invest or pay off my mortgage and
i'm a long time listener of the show and
i know that
you always say that you know if i'm
already investing 15
then i should go ahead and throw extra
money on the mortgage
and i guess two parts of this is
you know i still have about 430 000 on
the mortgage
but i think we're probably going to move
in the next two to three years
and so thinking about it you know the
inheritance is 150
000 so i can't completely pay off the
mortgage
and i'm concerned that i would earn more
you know investing that for two years
and getting a good return
rather than you know what the house
might appreciate in the two years before
we move and so i was hoping you could
better explain why you recommend
the mortgage route in this situation the
house is going to appreciate exactly the
same amount whether it has debt on it or
not
sure so you putting 150 on it doesn't
cause more appreciation
uh the only savings you would have would
be the interest rate on the that amount
of debt
uh whatever your mortgage interest rate
is and as compared to what you might
make on a mutual fund that might be
small
uh to your point to your concern uh
i would put it on the mortgage anyway
and the reason is that i am going to
have a paid off mortgage whether it's
selling this property and moving the
equity to another property
but i'm gonna have a paid off home as a
part of your financial plan
as soon as i possibly can because all of
the data
with all the millionaires that we work
with uh from the millionaire study that
hogan did
says that there's two primary things
that cause people to have their first
million dollar net worth
and first one to five million dollar net
worth and that is their 401k
retirement savings yes and you're not
going to put it in that because it's
payroll deduct
and um and a paid off home mortgage
it is we did not find a
single millionaire out of 10 000 of them
that we studied that said
i became wealthy because i never paid
off my home
and i used all of that money to invest
right right all of them
either had their homes paid off or were
heading
towards having their homes paid off they
never once said oh i
i would never pay off my home because i
always want to invest
and one key thing she she said there
today was she thinks
so yeah so still put it on the mortgage
because things may change too
if you don't if you do stay you can pay
off the mortgage if you don't stay
uh you know they're going to give you
that money at the closing when you sell
the house
exactly in the form of equity and come
back to you so you don't lose the money
what you are going to lose potentially
in the short term
is what you would have made in a mutual
fund versus
your mortgage interest rate which might
be
fifteen thousand bucks a year might be
two thousand bucks a year something like
that um
but i i'm going with the data and the
data says
paid off home one step to being
millionaire and i'm always going to move
that direction and so that keeps me
right on those baby steps
you can certainly do what you want to do
that's what i would do this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage aaron and whitley are with us
whitney are with us hey guys how are you
good good how are you welcome where do
you guys live
franklin furnace ohio oh fun welcome to
nashville
what brings you all the way here a
debt-free scream i assume
yes sir awesome how much of you guys
paid off
we paid off 30 thousand dollars in six
months all right
way to go and your range of income
during that time uh
started out about 54 and ended up about
80.
okay cool what do you guys do for a
living i'm a
service technician for a telephone
internet provider
a stay-at-home mom oh very cool he's got
the hard job
yeah for real so you kicked in some
overtime or picked up some extra jobs
huh
yeah a lot of overtime probably about a
thousand hours overtime
you've been kicking it man oh yeah way
to go dude set your family free huh
oh yeah thirty thousand dollars in six
freaking months
tell us about this what got you so fired
up uh
well we've been just fighting it forever
and ever man it's just like no matter
what we did nothing worked
um she actually went to financial peace
probably about
six months before we got real heavy into
it uh
i didn't have anything to do with it and
then i was working out of town and
then it became my idea so
okay how come he wasn't first how come
he went into it at first
uh i i wasn't like she she was going to
church at the time
and i was just led way far astray
she brought me back and you know
here we are okay all right so tell us
the story whitney what do you what
happened from your perspective
um they just had a class at church and
our pastor
led it um and then i just kept pushing
you know
you need to listen to dave ramsey you
need to listen and he was hesitant but
then
finally when it was his idea he was on
board
okay all right so you just started
listening to podcasts while you're out
of town or what
yeah we picked up a lot of overtime so i
was driving to lexington kentucky it's
probably about
two hours yeah um and i mean you can't
do nothing while you're driving i just
ended up finding you and then i started
downloading the podcast and i mean i
just
it just ate it all up man boom just like
that
so you guys decide to okay we're gonna
do the financial piece university the
dave ramsey stuff wide open
we're gonna get on a budget we're gonna
get out of debt what happened
uh we put disney world on a credit card
and that's
really what set it off yeah oh wow
so how did that say this last trip huh
yeah i had this hair brain idea that you
know if you don't
you get these credit cards and you uh
well we'll just put all our bills on
this and we'll get
you know the 50 points or whatever and
it doesn't work so don't do that
[Laughter]
so whitney he comes home and says now
it's my idea and you went finally
yes yeah okay all right
so what was the hardest part of getting
out of debt all the extra hours i guess
but yeah i'm getting on the same page i
would say
for me i'm the free spender
didn't want to give up anything but then
once we got a budget
we didn't really give up as much as i
thought how did y'all do a budget with
uh with aaron working so many hours
um uh my brother my oldest brother he is
a
super nerd so he's like he loves
spreadsheets and stuff and i just
asked him one day to help us with us and
we downloaded it on our phones
uh google sheets and we punched
everything in
and that you know once a week or once
every two weeks we'd have a budget
meeting and
at first it was hard but now it's it's
like the most exciting day of the week
for me
oh bad that's so cool what was what
would you say is
the secret that you want to tell
everyone to young people listening to
you right now what should they be doing
right now well here's one thing why
should they get out of debt
um because like even right now i feel
like we're
kind of ahead of the game but we're
really not i mean we're i'm 33 she's 31
and i just think back all the dumb stuff
we did
you know decades ago on how much money
like we would have right now
and it's just uh it's it's
it's fun being weird i'll just say that
yeah how does it feel to be completely
done
amazing yeah free right yes yeah yeah
yeah since it so we started you know
back uh was january last year
so we was out of debt in july
and here we are february this year and
we're on step five so
wow i mean we we cash flow
we cash flowed a down payment for our
new old house
uh we you know just it's awesome wow way
to go you guys
congratulations feels good huh what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
uh for me it's just patience
one of the verses that really helped me
is romans 5 3
it says we glory and tribulations
because tribulations
uh bring forth patience which brings
forth
experience character and hope yep so i
mean if you just stay that course
you can get through anything so wait
wait wait you see what just happened
today i did it he just quoted scripture
he just quoted scripture i heard that
and six months ago he wasn't in the
church i heard that this
is what i'm talking about there you go
i'm more excited about this and you
paying off your debt i ain't gonna lie
that's good man and that's one of my
favorite scriptures i love her
okay then rejoice in your suffering i
don't think so
well suffering produces perseverance and
perseverance character and character
hope and hope is a gift of the holy
spirit yeah well done guy that's awesome
man thank you
very cool i love it good for you guys
so fun and the kiddos uh what are their
names and ages bring them into the shot
uh braden is 14 and amelia is four
so have they been tracking with you on
this or you've been dragging them yeah
we dragged uh braden we actually read
through uh
the smart money smart kids oh wow so
and it must be sinking in because he
just his ipad
that he had for like i don't know seven
eight years crapped out
and he bought his own new ipad
whoa where'd he go man yeah well done
i told him if he gets any scholarship
too we have a five percent
cash back so ah he's been hitting that
pretty hard too
nice very nice well you guys you've
changed your family tree
you not only changed the way you you had
a little bit of debt you cleaned up but
on top of that you changed your life
your marriage
your parenting everything i'm so proud
of you well done guys
very very well done excellent job good
stuff
all right aaron and whitney braden and
amelia
lexington ky area thirty thousand
dollars paid off
in six months making 54 to 80 lots of
hard work in ot
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done right there man
that is fun
oh you know these stories almost always
contain the part
where for a married couple anyway yeah
where the other one had to get on board
yep
and when that happens it's like ding
ding here we go and they clicked
game on and it clicked game on here
sounds like it even helped their
marriage dave
yeah absolutely no question about it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five sam is with us in hawaii hi sam how
are you
hi mr ramsey good to talk to you you too
i'm short on time give me a question
right quick
okay so um we just got a newborn baby
and uh uh
the the girlfriend is at home with the
kids so we got a single income
uh i'm a full-time uber driver and i've
accumulated some traffic tickets
um that i think might be affecting my
background check
and uh i'm thinking if the background
check doesn't go through i'll be out of
a job
in the meantime i also just found out i
have
eight thousand dollars in taxes after
all this coming year
in april what do you make in revenue
what would be
about 4 000 a month and what is the uh
tax what are the
uh the traffic tickets cost
the traffic tickets are about 1200.
we'll take them out first
yep and then you got to get on this you
got to get on those taxes and you got to
get on it hard
you're probably gonna you're gonna need
to file your income tax return
on time even if you don't pay
and then you you contact the irs about
what's called an
installment plan and put that on
payments until you can clear it and dude
you want to clear it as fast as possible
because the penalties and the uh
interest are ridiculous dealing with the
irs plus they have almost unlimited
power so
you're not probably not going to quite
clear it all by april 15th
but you get the tickets cleared first
and then get after the irs fast but by
mid-summer it all needs to be gone
and oh you got to start setting back
your quarterly estimates so you don't
know taxes next year
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're wondering if you
should be
buying or selling a home or if you
should put it on hold
well this is a big financial decision
and big financial decisions should
happen on your timeline
well dave i'm panicking because of the
pandemic dave i'm panicking because of
interest rates and dave
listen every time you're panicking if
you start your sentence with i'm
panicking
or i'm afraid everything after the
sentence is something you shouldn't do
don't do stuff because you're afraid
that's never i mean unless it's get out
of the way of a car
or dodge a snake but other than that you
don't need to make decisions when you're
afraid they're always bad decisions
fear does not induce clarity
quite the opposite so don't wait around
for the stars to align
to buy a home or sell a home truth is
you can win in
any market in any season if you put the
right people on your team if you want to
find a top real estate agent in your
area like one of our endorsed local
providers our elps
they use years of experience and success
and change in
changing markets to serve you they know
what things look like they know what's
happening out there
and that's the only agent in your area i
trust if you want to make a move that's
right for your family text
house 233 789
33789 text the word
house and you'll get somebody in your
corner to help you
and you'll make much better decisions
not time to make decisions when you're
scared right right absolutely dave
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today claire is in idaho
falls idaho hi claire how are you
hi dave good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hi um me and my husband we're graduating
college
we've made it out debt free yay um
yeah so he's doing software engineering
so we're going to move
just wherever he gets a job because he's
going to make more than i do
um i've been working putting him through
school
just working at the courthouse and there
i have about
two thousand dollars that i've put away
in the retirement fund
um through my work i'm not going to
continue working there
so i'm wondering if i should you know
pull the 2000 for my retirement and then
what i should do with it ah no you
should never pull from your retirement i
don't care if it's only a thousand
dollars
uh what i want you to do is transfer
that over claire to a traditional ira
uh get on the phone with a smart
investor pro or you could possibly do
that yourself with two thousand dollars
but i would suggest a smart investor pro
and just let it sit there and start
investing into the ira moving forward
until you both land a job and then go
back into uh your matches
then you're roth then traditionals those
are the three main things i teach and we
actually teach
when it comes to investing but do not
pull it out don't spend it
go ahead and transfer it into your
retirement age direct transfer
rollover into an ira is what he's
talking about with a smart investor pro
and they can help you pick a mutual fund
to do that
it's not the end of the world if you
cash out a two thousand dollar account
it's just kind of silly to give the
government half your money
right and that's what you're gonna do so
i wouldn't do it uh we don't cash out
retirement accounts as unless it's to
avoid bankruptcy or foreclosure
you're certainly you know not going to
have either one of those
in this situation tracy's in lexington
kentucky hi
tracy welcome to the ramsey show how can
we help
hi dave i have a quick question i think
it's pretty cut and garage
to whether or not to hit i'm 53 years
old my husband's a retired school
teacher i still i started late i spent
time with the kids so i'm
seven to nine years before i can get
before
multiple full teacher pensions my
question is
we have 14 years left on our home
mortgage at
a rate of two points our interest rate
is 2.75
do we continue to get outside of our
pension now
we'll both have a pension we have 401k
and raw
what should i be hitting the hardest
with the market returns it looks like
the 401k
returns much better than 2.75 which is
on our
home mortgage are you free except your
home
no we have 17 000 on one vehicle
before we even have this discussion that
has to go
okay so your number one thing is
clearing that up
do you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
yes how much uh
right at twenty thousand oh good pay
your car off today yeah
oh okay yeah that's all yeah
then then your next number one wait
you're then your number one goal and i
want you to do a written
detailed budget with your husband your
number one goal is to build your
emergency fund back
up yeah we'll show his annual income
um right out right at 100. good so this
is gonna you're gonna do this very
quickly
very quickly very quickly if you're not
willing to pay the car off today you
should sell it
yeah okay because you've already
you're already owned the car the only
question is are you going to own the
debt so we're going to clear the debt
now you don't have a car payment anymore
we're going to build your emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
that's going to take you about four
months is all
and then we're gonna start baby step
four
which is 15 of your income going into
retirement
and everything else we can find we're
going to throw at that house yeah
okay okay and i i think i'm at
nine eight eight percent into my
retirement already i forgot to mention
that
that's already you need to yeah you may
want to stop that temporarily until you
get that emergency fund rebuilt
and then start it again at 15 and that's
household incomes your husband worked
um he is currently starting a second of
business he's a
with a retired teacher and he's
currently starting but that's
not income anything expense nor income
at the moment
okay if it starts creating an income 15
of your household income
goes into retirement that's what we call
baby step four
that's when you're debt free with an
emergency fund that's the first three
steps
then four is 15 of your income going
into retirement everything above 15
and by the way without this big stinking
car payment and by living on a budget
you're going to have money above the 15
to go ahead and clear that mortgage off
because in seven years i want this house
gone
our house debt gone and when you move
into retirement you're gonna have a
healthy 401k
a healthy pension he's going to have a
business going
and you're going to have a paid for
house that's where you want to be at
retirement
yep right yeah that's my goal
i come i have a money fear i'm one of
those people whose parents didn't do
they did everything i shouldn't do so i
have
almost irrational fear of not having
money when i'm
older well the step that we gave you
gives you both wealth and stability yes
wealth is in the 401k stabilities in the
paid for house
right and the the process i just gave
you is the shortest distance
between where you are and there okay
15 into retirement after the truck's
paid pay off the truck for sale
after the emergency fund's in place
after emergency fund's back in place
okay then 15
into retirement and everything else we
can squeeze out of the budget we chunk
on the house
how much do you owe on your home uh
184
yeah it's going to be it's probably
going to be seven to nine years before
you're done
yeah you may not have it done in seven
years but you're going to be close
depending on if your husband starts
adding some income to the equation or
not
yeah and he starts adding income to the
equation you start throwing it at that
and don't allow your fear tracy to
prevent you from getting to your
your purpose as far as not your purpose
but your future pay off the car today
all right
pay it off today and you'll get closer
and closer and closer to your dream i
think you can do it within seven to
eight years
um but the numbers do show seven and
nine but i think if you and your husband
really sit down get on a clear budget
i think you can be there within seven
years twenty five thousand dollars
is eight years out of a hundred
sure you can do it faster than that
probably you probably can do it in
because the income should go up with the
business yeah yeah i i do i think you're
gonna be done in seven years
if you stay concentrating on it right i
mean you don't have to live on beans and
rice to do it but i think you're just
going to pay attention
yeah just be very intentional with your
money hang on i'm going to send you a
copy of the book the total money
makeover which outlines those baby steps
that we were using in detail
it's like the baby steps on steroids
that's what the book is and it's the
best selling book we've ever done
because of that because it gives
everybody a clear path of exactly what
to do here
what to do there what to do there and
what to do there that's simple
and so um very very cool good stuff
we appreciate you calling in all right
anthony that about puts another hour
down well done know the hour
it's been fun dave i like rock and roll
james childs is our producer kelly
daniel is our associate producer i'm
dave
ramsey your host this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice anthony o'neil ramsey
personality
is my co-host today i am dave ramsey
your host open phones at triple eight
eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two dion is in
bakersfield california
starting this hour off hi dion how are
you how you doing dave finally got the
chance to talk to you and i'm sorry i'm
trying to
this is my first time talking i don't
know how to do all this but i'm trying
i've been reaching out trying to reach
out to your company for
years now this is my first time well i'm
glad you got through how can we help you
today
um i just purchased my first home
and two years ago i'm trying to figure
out a way
as a blind person how to pay off my
mortgage faster than
30 years okay okay dion
did you say a blind person
excuse me i'm sorry did you say a blind
person
yes sir okay so what do you do for a
living
i receive social security okay all right
and how expensive a home did you buy in
bakersfield california
uh it's actually right next door to in
lancaster but
it's uh we paid 240 000.
you said we are you married via yes sir
okay
what does she do for a living she's a um
caregiver she takes care of her elderly
okay so what's your household income
then
uh i received social security 900 a
month she receives about
2 600 a month okay
after we moved into our house she was
taking care of one of the
people she was taken care of and um
their spouse passed away and we took
them
in and we've been doing it so we take
care of elderly in our home as well
and what does that pay
we receive about we have two patients
right now we
receive about twenty two hundred dollars
straight across money
oh okay okay so that's about fifty five
hundred a month yeah that makes
that makes that makes us a little bit i
didn't think you were paying a
mortgage on a two hundred something
thousand dollar house with thirty six
hundred bucks so this is helpful
good okay good so you did that because
you had this mortgage and you had to do
something right
yes sir good well no well actually my
dad was living with us before he passed
away too so that was another reason why
we were able to
get the house and my wife was receiving
i had more patience at the time before
the coronavirus
gotcha so what's your question for today
then
i'm trying to find out how to pay off my
home faster i've been
hearing stuff i've compared all faster
than 30 years i've been following you
since i've been
since i was 16. i'm 52 now so before we
go there uh
dion do you have any other consumer debt
excluding your mortgage
no we don't have any credit card debt we
pay all credit cards in
full every month we own both of our cars
so no we don't have any debt at all so
you do have debt you just paid off every
month
oh well i i follow stupid people and
tell me about credit cards
because he said he has credit cards and
he pays it off every month oh okay but
you don't have a balance on them so yeah
yeah so you're going to get debit cards
to replace those but then
as far as paying off the house early you
just we're going to put you on a budget
make sure you have your emergency fund
in place
and start saving 15 of your income
towards retirement
past that every dollar you can find up
to baby step six is gonna go towards the
house
unless i miss something that's where he
is yeah no he didn't miss nothing at all
dave i mean i definitely want to say
uh get rid of the credit cards though i
mean because that's going to put you
back into debt
um eventually i i'm just going to say
that so first time there's a hiccup
you're going to end up
and you're going to look over on those
things there's going to be a balance
he's right about that but
um i think the big thing here is is you
guys have done a great job of scrap
being scrappy
you're hustling you're grinding you're
adding you know adding people into your
home that you're taking care of she's
working
you know you guys are doing everything
you can do to make sure that you make
the payments on this house
and you've always figured out a way you
know and so
that's good news right and i would just
use that scrappiness and not use it as a
way to
uh save your bacon every time but
instead be a way that you
uh that you're actually prospering and
that comes from working the baby steps
and doing that with
a budget and you know baby step one is
debt free
except the home you've done that two is
an emergency fund of three to six months
or two is debt snowball three is
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
and you move straight up through that
process yeah
james is with us in seattle hi james
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave anthony thank you guys for
taking my call sure what's up
um so my wife and i are considering
quitting our jobs and going back to
school she
wants to do a career change and i kind
of want to accelerate my master's
program
it's in a it's a four-year program it's
a part-time program and i kind of want
to get it done in two years
uh so we were uh considering uh quitting
our jobs
um we make combined 220
and uh the only debt that we have left
is our house which we owe about 130 on
um so you want to get your max version
what
my master's it's my mba it's in it's an
executive mba yeah um i'm a corporate
controller a financial controller right
now and
i would like what now i make 130 and she
makes 90.
and you'd like to be a cfo yeah i'd like
to be a cfo my goal is by 35. and you
think you have to have an mba to be a
cfo
um you know i've been looking a lot and
they usually require like a
cpa which i have and an mba i think that
would help
with um you know i don't have a ton of
years of experience
um my cfo this is a 300 million dollar
company my cfo does not have an mba
oh gotcha yeah just as a history
yeah just a heads up yeah i'm okay if
you go get it no quitting your job to go
get it
quitting is a bit extreme yeah jobs not
just job jobs
because both y'all want to quit what is
what's her degree field what's she
wanting to go do
um she wanted to do um she wanted to get
she wanted to be a lawyer and then
she decided that she didn't want to do
that she's got her four-year degree
and she's a paralegal she actually wants
to switch to health care management
okay and she has a four-year degree in
what
uh pre-law okay and what does she do now
she's a paralegal now she's a paralegal
okay and she wants to move into the
health care field
and so she wants to get a master's in
that management she wants to get a
master's degree she either wants to
uh she wants to get like a four-year
degree in her uh health care management
how old are you guys for her master's in
healthcare i'm 31 she's 29.
okay okay well i i have
a we have we share
a view of education that
um with a few rare exceptions the
primary use of education is to increase
income
yeah and to move into a career field
that you love okay
and so um it is not something that you
just collect like thermo degrees on a
thermometer
and it is not something that you
have to have it is is what is necessary
for you to go win and um
in your case i would do the mba as an
executive level and keep your position
uh would definitely not quit in her case
i would probably do the same thing i'd
probably pick up some night classes
and begin to move towards health care as
a career move rather than just quit your
jobs
you're making a great income i think you
can make a more gentle transition than
this
and i think you should
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people uh you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same doctor
financial life
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're trying to find
the perfect valentine's gift
consider this your suggestion
in order to make real progress with your
money you got to be on the same page as
your spouse
and to make progress with your marriage
you got to be on the same page with your
spouse and you need to work together
being on the same page with your spouse
to create a budget
to help you get on the same page we've
gathered up our best-selling books our
budgeting tools
and we bundles for couple all couples
all in one big
sale for valentine's you can save up to
83 percent
check it out at daveramsey.com and you
do not want to miss
this coming friday the big money and
marriage live stream february the 12th
join rachel cruz best-selling author and
emotional
wellness expert dr john deloney also
best-selling author
as they walk you and your spouse through
a fun date night
that will help you have better
conversations deeper connections
and faster progress with your money
visit us at daveramsey.com
backslash store and you can get your
live stream tickets and your valentine's
day gifts
that will help you build a bright future
with your spouse
sale ends february 14th again the money
and marriage live stream is this coming
friday
february the 12th for those of you that
are
already ramsey plus members it is free
to you
so you don't want to miss out on that
check it all out
i am dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsey show anthony o'neil my co-host
joins me today ramsey personality
matthew is with us
in cleveland ohio hi matthew how are you
hey guys how you doing thanks for taking
my phone call sure
quick question um i just got done
reading the total money makeover i'm in
the middle of a debt free degree right
now both great books really love them
thank you
um my wife and i are in the process
of um planning out our budget and
looking through our debt and seeing what
we owe we've already got
enough money in the bank for baby step
one so i guess we'd currently be on baby
step two
good so in in the total money makeover
um i believe you said to
divest from your retirement investments
um
temporarily no just stop actually not
don't take the money out yeah
i'm sorry i'm yeah i apologize that's
right i'm sorry that's okay
um to stop adding uh so
like between my wife and i that's
probably almost 500
a month which um but my my question is
in regards to
uh my son's 529 so i've got
a 15 year old son who's actually the
youngest of three i've got two that are
in college right now
one pace board herself um and the other
one
we're helping with the oldest one's got
kids and
she's single so she's basically getting
college for free
um through grants and scholarships
um so sh we i actively contribute like a
hundred dollars a month towards this 529
and he's already in high school and
there's not terribly much money in there
about 5500 bucks in there but
my question is do we also do the same
with that stop actively contributing in
that
what's your household income
gross is about 150. okay 100 bucks a
month
100 bucks a month is 1200 a year
for three years before he goes to
college is 3 600
yeah right this does not solve your
college problem it doesn't
right so that's
my i was asking what i was actually
thinking of doing was leaving it in
and i know i you're gonna i know bad
idea with uh student loans but
what we were looking at dealing with
leaving it in and letting it grow for
the other four years and then taking
what we have
after the additional four years after
the seven total years and putting that
down
off of whatever we can't afford yeah
instead what i would tell you to do
is let's work the baby steps
and um if you're reading debt-free
degree you know he doesn't
he you don't have to have all the money
saved for him to go to college he just
has to choose properly yeah
so we're going to work for baby steps
you're going to be how much debt do you
have not counting your home
um numbers-wise i haven't finished
adding it up
it's over hunter um my wife and i both
have student loans and then we co-signed
for
um not cosign but we have parent loans
for my other son
actually my student my student loans are
actually going to be paid off
in may of this year because i'm a
government worker so
i'll have made my 120 on time payments
and i did talk to
yeah matthew who's the first thing um
the first thing you need to know exactly
what are you up against you need to know
your numbers
okay before you can really fix this
situation you need to know exactly to
the t
how much debt that you're in so this
means you need it on the budget okay so
that's the very first thing
we've got we've got leases on cars which
we're working on trying to get out of
good um so that's part of it
um we lease our cell phones which we're
gonna we're gonna
throw into the snowball and get rid of
uh very soon good
the only other mortgage we the only only
other debt we have after that is our
student loans yeah um cars are student
loans
okay yeah yeah so you've got it
the point being making what you make i
think
it sounds like you are going to be debt
free
except your home by the time your 15
year old gets to school
you'll have your emergency fund in place
and
um i would love for you to put 15 of
your income away beginning with baby
step 4
towards retirement and then cash flow is
college beyond that
if you put retirement on hold for a
couple of years to cash flow his college
oh by the way he's going to do all the
other things in debt-free degree in
order to go to college
yeah but you should map out a thing to
where you are debt-free before he gets
to school
baby step two and have your emergency
fund in place
and then with 150 000 income and using
the debt free degree plan you ought to
be able to cash flow his college no
student loans
and i would have stopped your retirement
during that time
until you get there and i would have
stopped his 529
until you get there um and you're
probably never going to restart it
because by the time you get there you're
probably going to be writing checks for
college yeah and matthew have a
conversation with your son now
let him know like hey your college
experience will be based upon your
grades
your scholarships based upon you so if
you really want to go to this particular
school
inside of ohio you're going to have to
step up to the plate
now is a great time to have that
conversation with them and make sure
that he's reading the book
with you because we walk you through the
step-by-step process what are the
classes
how does he prep for the act in the sat
make sure that he's playing a huge part
of that
and you're not just carrying all the
weight okay because if he gets good
scores on those and takes the classes
and takes them again
and super scores them that's going to
qualify him for yet more scholarships
he's going to be working while he's in
school and he's going to choose a school
the two of you together are going to
choose a school that you can afford
in ohio yeah it's going to be an
in-state state school yes
uh he's not going to a 100 000 year
school no you don't have that money
he's also not driving a bentley no
because and there's no shame in either
one of those
and he might even go to community
college for the first year or two
to get some of his basics out of the way
before he transfers to a four-year
so any of those plans and all of those
plans
get this kid through school debt-free uh
and you're going to be able to help
a lot just out of your monthly budget
yes because you're not going to have
any payments except your house payment
by the time you get there but you're
going to take the radical steps to do
that i sure hope
that your theory on the student loan
forgiveness works out it has not worked
out for hardly anyone
virtually no one has gotten that
approved uh
and so there's uh i saw the staff the
other day it's up to i think it's up to
30
000 people have now gotten their
forgiveness but it's 400 000 have
applied and didn't
did yep and so um you know and of course
current political arguments are there's
going to be some forgiveness in addition
to that i
will see but uh um
[Music]
you know i i you've got to lay out a
game plan to where you clear this debt
these car
leases these student loans these parent
loans 100
get your emergency fund in place only
then do you restart your 401k
and you lay out a detailed game plan to
cash flow college using the debt free
degree
so book and process to do that yes and i
think it's all possible
absolutely but basically uh seven years
from today
yeah three years more of high school
four more years of that you know you're
gonna be
you're the last one off the payroll yeah
and um
that's that's what we called it when our
kids left they got them off the payroll
now they're on this payroll
i like that picture though yeah that's
it they're off the payroll
you can do it it's just gonna have to be
very detailed and very intentional
and uh no wavering and no waffling
like those cars don't need to be still
sitting in the driveway the freaking
payment on them
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
matt and sarah are with us in
minneapolis it says on my screen you
guys are
debt free congratulations
[Music]
well done how much have you paid off
um 141 000. cool how long did this take
uh it took me 17 months okay and your
range of income during that time
uh we started at about 235 thousand
and we ended at two hundred and eighty
thousand
wow what do you do for a living
um i am in software sales i'm in
physical therapy okay wow cool
so i'm guessing some of this 141 must
have been student loan debts
well you guessed right
how much was it so the student debt was
about 130
000 um and then the remainder is about
seven thousand for auto
and then the rest was just impressive
i'm having trouble hearing you you're
gonna have to get where you could talk
directly into your phone
okay how much was the student loan debt
against
130 for the student loans okay
good oh my gosh so 11 wasn't about 4 000
for credit card
okay so tell us the story what happened
17 months ago that got you guys started
on all this
uh i mean we really just got sick and
tired of being sick and tired
i mean we had two we have two little
kids and
we really just wanted to you know be
able to
you know have the future for them that
you know we wanted for our family and it
was just getting kind of ridiculous
because
we you know had an awesome income but we
felt like we were broke and we
you know kind of finally just came
across some of your books
um and actually we started listening to
our podcast
and we really started getting gazelle
intense
after we listened to our first debt free
stream
um that we kind of hit home with us and
really inspired us and got us motivated
and we just got
gazelle intense since then wow very cool
good for you guys so you did it a
hundred and forty one thousand
in 17 months that's like seven eight
thousand bucks a month
yeah you're chunking on this man i mean
this is big time
uh so what do you tell people the key
the the thing they have to know
if they're gonna get out of debt what
are the keys
the well the key the first key for us
was 100
the every dollar budget um well like i
said
maybe take a step back but why so we
really thought about why we want to do
this and
that was so important because so many
times during this we would
um fall off even for like a week and
then we would get back to why we were
doing it and
that would get us back and motivated and
then we
use that gazelle intensity when we did
have that
focus and then the budget just to keep
us on track because
yeah we were definitely spending more
than uh than we were
meant to be spending at that moment yeah
so what's your big why
well definitely just being able to
be outrageously generous i mean it kind
of started
like i said heading home when we just
heard all the people on your show
saying like we want to live like no one
else so that later we can live and
give like no one else and
you know we want to be able to do that
and we felt like
we were you know we should be able to do
that but if we never
get rid of this debt that we're never
going to be in a winning situation
um and so that was really kind of our
big why
yeah so what was the hardest thing
throughout this journey throughout these
last 17 months
the hardest thing oh well
i think i mean we just there were so
many
you know bonus and commission checks
that came in and
i remember just kind of crying like each
time one came in
because i knew that we didn't get to do
anything with it like
i couldn't buy a new car we couldn't
um you know kind of do all the things
that we saw other people doing
right and we knew that it just had to go
to our debt
um so i think that was definitely the
hardest thing is just
you know stop comparing to other people
and just kind of run your race
um but we stuck with it
so good very very good very cool
well done so now that you're out how's
it feel
amazing i really still can't believe it
i mean it's we've and again we've heard
this on your show so many times but
we've started making
such different decisions because
of you know our ability now to not
you know have like five six seven
thousand dollars
going towards debt every month um so
it's really
it's really i would like to say change
our family tree
yeah so most of the student loan debt
was from my
as if you from them it was like it felt
like there was a constant chain
um just holding me back all the time
with this and it finally just felt like
i was free
um and and not having that burden
on my shoulders at all times and it's
just been
so um relieving and we feel like we can
make decisions that we never would have
even thought about before
so for example we we just decided uh
this month that we're going to start our
own business
and that is was completely um not even
imaginable
three years ago yeah yeah wow
very cool this is exciting so proud of
you guys
very well done yeah yeah we appreciate
it we uh
we uh took what you said to heart and it
made all the world of a difference
yeah you guys are incredible we've got a
copy of chris hogan's book for you
every day millionaires there's no doubt
that that is the next chapter in your
story you have this fabulous income
and you have this ability to control
money now instead of it or the lack of
it controlling you you guys have worked
together
you're a team you've done everything the
right way
very very well done congratulations it's
not a perfect process
but it gets you there and now you're
free yeah so
very well done thank you
matt and sarah minneapolis minnesota 141
000 paid off in 17 months making 235 to
280.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love it well done you two
very very well done tyler is in kansas
city
hi tyler how are you i'm well how are
you guys doing
better than we deserve you got a little
football hangover today
no so i am a king tom fan so i'm really
excited about how yesterday went oh man
you're on pot you're unpopular in your
own neighborhood yeah man
we're going we're going to end this car
right now
[Laughter]
how can we help you today sir well yeah
thank you for
uh taking my call yeah i've been a big
big fan
of your show for a while dave and read
the total money makeover as a wedding
gift my wife and i
um as of monday last week we were
officially
on baby step four i submitted my uh
application or whatever on fidelity to
get my uh
retirement funded feels good now that
i'm on babies
what was that it was good doesn't it it
does
but now that i'm here it's like you know
i kept pushing to get to
through baby step three and now that
we're here it's like now what
that's why that's why i thought i'd give
you a quick call
um so my question is twofold i've been
reading
several books one of which is rich dad
poor dad and he talks a lot about asset
generating
um or inc asset generating income but uh
i
i know what you'll say to me right now
so i'm going to ask that question the
question i'm having
is i'm wondering i'm in a career where
i i work in a public accounting firm
where i
don't make quite as much as the market
pays so i'm in a position where i'd be
able to leave
where i'm at right now for a fairly
significant pay bump
like what's that what do you make now
what would you make if you left
yeah yeah great question so right now i
make 67
and i've had several friends leave
within the last couple years and they're
both
over 100 probably close to 110. if you
could get a
quality firm with quality people why
would you not do that
yeah so and i don't know this is the
question that i'm still trying to
reconcile is
the the thing that we've been kind of
hounded on through college
all right tell you what you hold on we
come back from this break we'll get the
rest of your question
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 13 11
wealth gained hastily will dwindle but
whoever gathers
little by little will increase it
winston churchill said continuous effort
not strength
or intelligence is the key to unlocking
our potential anthony o'neil ramsey
personality is my co-host today we're
talking with tyler
in kansas city he's in public accounting
has a job making sixty seven thousand as
the opportunity baby step four just got
there
it's the opportunity to possibly take uh
a position making
almost double that somewhere else and uh
i said
well if the people are high quality why
in the firm is high quality why would
you not do that
and you were beginning to explain
something to us as we headed into the
commercial tyler what was that
yeah thanks for coming back yeah so and
this is kind of goes back to the
what we've been we being accounting
majors have been taught throughout
uh college is there's a certain
threshold that you hit
like it's almost you know it's a
five-year benchmark that you hit in
public accounting and at that point
you've kind of earned your stripes and
then you've increased your earnings
potential
and so it's almost like a long game a
long-term game that they're
that you know i'm trying to think
long-term that if you leave before this
five years you've limited
your earnings but to your point
you know if i use my sorry i'm confused
if you stay making half of what you can
make
you are earning your stripes how
yeah this is this is the conundrum that
we you know i've been
wondering is it you get a title that
sounds like something from the 1950s
it's very archaic no but it's not you
know the truth is
is that the money to be made in your
field
is not in public accounting
long term it would be but that's 10 15
years out
well building a book of business uh yeah
once you're a partner and it's about
your book of business and it's
much more lucrative but as a first
couple years it's
it's certainly not i see okay so you're
on a model where you're trying to make
partner much like a law student
where they work your butt off you get
nothing for five years and then
hopefully you can get your foot in the
door
it's just yeah it's very similar yeah
okay all right
so that's what you mean by that so if
you went the other direction why would
you not be on the same track
you're you're working you know you're
working for a a corporation doing
accounting at that point you're not up
for partner
you're not going to stay in that world
is that what you're saying yes okay so
what does a partner make it's a place
you work now
yeah it's kind of a smoke and mirrors
question but i would say probably close
to
800 depending on market and clients but
800 and above okay and you're how far
out from that
oh 14 years yeah
yeah and to be pretty candid that's not
really
where i want to live you know i'm not
real sure where i want to go but i'm
pretty sure i don't want to be a partner
so it's
almost a question of is it worth
sticking around longer
for potential higher earnings outside of
public accounting because i stayed
longer here
if that makes sense yeah i think i'm
moving on
yeah i'm glad you said that dave that's
just my inclination
and because i think that the other thing
that i see with folks
um you know in your field is is that
there's a lot of entrepreneurial
opportunities that open up over time
that you use your finance and accounting
expertise in
uh that can even be in a startup
situation where you would make even more
than you might have made where your
partner in a
medium-sized firm so there's a lot of
different ways your career could bend
and twist and turn over the years
um but um you know number one i think
the the key thing here of what you said
is
you don't really like the destination so
why go 14 years to get there
yeah that answers my question
that's definitely something that i've
been you know on the ken coleman
episodes in his show you know that's one
of the things that i often think about
as well so
it's the old thing of if you climb the
ladder of success and it's leaning on
the wrong building oh crap
yep yeah you know
and so you know we want to make sure the
stinking ladder is leaning in the right
place now
you know so what i've discovered is is
that the economy and the career path
these days is a lot more dynamic
and a lot more fluid than just
one possible path for a given
field of endeavor i would have never
thought i would have been on the path i
ended up
on with a degree in finance and real
estate it was definitely not my intent
to end up going broke and then coaching
people on how not to do that but
uh it worked out okay for me you know so
it's a twist and a turn and you
you know you pivot and you uh play the
hand that's dealt you and so on so
uh it's in other words if you took the
other position and you were there five
years
making twice and you were piling up cash
during that time
that gives you the option to do other
things
if you wanted to take a a hard right or
hard left turn
utilizing some of those skills and again
go into an entrepreneurial startup of
some kind
or start your own public accounting firm
build your own book of business where
you
is the podna baby yes and uh that kind
of a thing
and you've got all kinds of options like
that and you know
uh with an extra four or five hundred
thousand dollars
uh in the next 10 years that would be
you know give it just give you a lot of
options so i just don't think it's going
to end up being a straight line to
success
and you don't like where the ladder is
leaning anyway so i'm standing there
i'm i'm i'm gonna go ahead and start
looking that other direction
yeah um so maybe you need to live your
dream not your professor's dream
so just my idea what do i know i like
that dave
open phones this hour simon is with us
simon's in tallahassee florida hi simon
how are you
hi dave hi anthony it's absolutely
delightful to speak to both of you
you too sir how can we help well i have
a real estate question for you um i'm a
young entrepreneur in tallahassee i have
student rental
business here and i'm having real
trouble finding reliable
affordable uh contractors plumbers etc
that actually show up to work and do the
job properly so i was wondering how you
went about finding proper contractors
that's a good question because i had the
same question for dave simon
no surprise you know when my son
15 years ago was in high school we were
doing a little bit of renovation
on our home and uh the guy wasn't
showing up and the guy wasn't showing up
and we're coming home one day and daniel
says uh
dad i'm he's 15 years old i'm going in
the construction business
i said why and he goes it's a really
easy business all you have to do is do
what you say
you were going to do and show up and you
have no competition
and it is it is i mean you can make if
you're a contractor you can make a mint
in that world by reasonably pricing
and showing up on time and uh doing what
you said you're gonna do keeping your
word
and uh to the point that uh too many
times people don't yeah
in that in that field so uh nick what we
have done over the years is number one
uh we have settled in like for our
rental properties and the properties
that we manage and that we own
we have settled on the fact that in
order to lower
our aggravation level we have increased
what we spend
to get a better person so you're you're
really not going to get
a super cheap contractor and get good
work
on time without problems it's just i
i have not had that as a experience
because most of the guys that are in
that world they charge a little more
because they know that they're the only
ones that are going to do the right job
on time the way they say it so and i'll
just pay a little more so i don't have
the
heartache of having to restart the
project four times with four different
people
that screw it up every time so i pay a
little bit more
uh not a lot more i'll pay double i
don't mean that but i'm i
i just changed my mindset on not
necessarily always going with the lowest
bid
and the second thing we do is is that we
are
100 of the time always looking
for more contractors
if we have a paint a guy that does
painting for us and we've got a really
good one right now he's an incredible
guy
um but we've always we're always looking
for another one
because i don't know what day he's not
gonna you know at what point he's gonna
blow up
yeah and so if i've got options
as backup i need i need some bench depth
and so just because i've got someone
that does good roofing doesn't mean i'm
going to only work with one roofer i'm
going to always have
another one on the bench ready to go and
just because i've got someone that's
good at building a deck
you know whatever whatever the thing is
that you're wanting done i want another
one
in queue yeah and uh pay a little more
and get some bench depth
and that's about the only way to avoid
the majority of the heartache
good question thank you for joining us
anthony good job today
dave america thank you that puts us hour
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
you